[Musique]
alors messieurs les censeurs du clavier
et du micro arrêté l'indécence et la
manipulation des motions des foules
cesser de faire croire qu'il y à 37
coeur à abattre et qu'ils sont tous
d'une majorité civique et borné dans cet
hémicycle
il ya des femmes et des hommes avec
chacun leur part quelles que soient
leurs convictions
quel que soit leur parti sur les buteurs
ont fait réveillez vous réveillant nous
nous parlons de la douleur absolue nous
parlons de la douleur absolue perdre un
enfant c'est perdre son avenir sa
projection personnelle dans l'éternité
on met du temps à l'accepter pas 5 pas
douze jours toute une vie à travers les
avancées du projet voté par la majorité
présidentielle à travers aussi les
expressions de colère ou de doute
moi j'entends une chose c'est que les
parents en deuil nous attendent pour
aller plus loin et pour l'or il ya
plusieurs questions qui n'ont pas été
traités faut en discuter avec les
acteurs
c'est ce que nous allons faire avec
adrien taquet avec les associations avec
les partenaires sociaux mais aussi avec
les parlementaires ce qui a animé la
majorité et pardon je m'exprime au nom
de la majorité ce qui animait le
gouvernement
ça n'était pas la mise en cause de ce
que une amélioration législatives était
utile et nécessaire
bien sûr que ça n'était pas la mise en
cause du dispositif particulier proposé
par monsieur le député prix qu à qui
jean rendre hommage c'est l'idée et je
voudrais aller au bout de ma réponse
monsieur le député c'est l'idée que les
éléments qui avaient été proposées ne
semblaient pas prendre en compte un
certain nombre de facteurs je jouais au
bout un certain nombre de facteurs qui
sont pourtant essentiels avons-nous
monsieur le député réussi à expliquer
cela la réponse est non las pivot a
provisoirement disparu du texte
tant mieux il ne doit pas y revenir car
cette mesure n'est en rien souhaitable
est injuste et des solutions
alternatives existent
nous avons étudié avec des collègues de
différents bords politiques
l'idée d'une majoration du taux de
cotisation de solidarité pour les très
hauts revenus par exemple pour les
revenus supérieurs à 5000 euros et 10000
euros par mois cela générerait en année
pleine jusqu'à 2 milliards d'euros de
recettes supplémentaires par an la
redistribution est au coeur du système
de retraite universel par répartition et
par point et que la finalité de ce
dispositif c'est d'augmenter
significativement de près de 30% la
pension de retraite des nouveaux sites
où nos concitoyens les plus fragiles les
plus vulnérables les retraités qui
touchent trop moins de 1400 euros par
mois donc la dynamique redistributif je
crois que nous appelons en scène aurait
bien présent n'irait pas au delà sur le
sujet de la cotisation à la question de
la rémunération des professeurs je vais
venir à la question de la rémunération
des professeurs oui il y a nécessité
d'améliorer la rémunération des
professeurs le premier à le dire c'est
votre serviteur je le dis depuis que je
suis arrivé en fonction nous avons
préparé ce chantier et maintenant il est
mûr pour arriver aux négociations
sociales dans lesquelles nous sommes
actuellement avec les organisations
syndicales
l'avenir me donnera raison vous le
verrez bien il faudra le reconnaître à
ce moment là puisque oui il aura des
augmentations substantielles
ça devrait vous réjouir on devrait être
ensemble parce que ces augmentations qui
n'ont pas eu lieu quand vous étiez au
pouvoir
elles vont avoir lieu avec cette
majorité
[Musique]